Back on inflammation topic, one remedy you mentioned so did to be like
Captain or Captain so curfew been so the remedy is in so you could just look if you look at our store
And you look at the product clear in flamm or in flammatone
It has a really good balance of the flammatones
So first thing you think of with with the inflammation is the flavonoids
So I'm I'm not looking at it right now, but clear in flamm has curfew been as well. Yeah, sticky dental
Borseted rosemary
Probably a few other ones
Another good product is the batallin
Which is not in that because their company that
Makes batallin has a has a patent on it
And it is the same company that makes the aloevia immune
It's it's called aloevia limitless
And that has been miraculous for some people
so
batallin is is there's much research on that as the most powerful anti-inflammatory
And so that comes in a blister pack
And you the very small little capsules but it's pure batallin
That's aloevia limitless is the day
And that can be extremely beneficial
Taking one to three of those a day can be extremely beneficial to decrease inflammation